yeah so so we do want to address exactly
that the question that was raised so one
way to think about it
that there's kind of a major conceptual
elephant in all of systems neuroscience
which is the following how is it that we
can record order say a hundred to a
thousand neurons in regions deep within
the brain far from the sensory motor
periphery and actually obtained
scientifically interpretable results
that relate neural activity to behavior
and cognition this is actually quite
remarkable considering that these brain
regions contain about ten to the six to
ten to the ninth neurons so so about
five orders of magnitude more neurons
than we than we currently record so a
question is how has systems neuroscience
been as successful as it has been in
such an under sample measurement regime
or is it worse are we completely
misleading ourselves by recording so few
neurons are we getting a dramatically
different view of the brain than we
might get if we recorded all the neurons
so that's what we'd like to address now
let's you think that there's just an
experimental solution to this problem
while it is the case that recording
technologies enable us to record more
and more neurons in fact the number of
neurons we can simultaneously record has
been has been growing exponentially so
this is a type of Moore's Law type of
growth but the doubling time is about
seven years right so right now we can
record a hundred to a thousand so it
would take about a hundred twenty years
to get five orders of magnitude more
neurons to to fully record entire neural
circuits and complex mammalian brains
controlling complicated behaviors so
we're gonna be in this under sample
measurement regime for the foreseeable
future and so what we need is we need a
theory of neural data analysis that
tells us how and when statistical
analyses applied to a small subset of
neurons reflect the collective dynamics
of a much larger unobserved circuit in
which they're embedded so that's the
question we'd like to address okay so
for the outline of the talk we'll start
with kind of trial average data how do
we talk about what I mean by all this
stuff Traverse data how do we accurately
recover the dimensionality and shape of
trial average neural dynamics and we'll
uncover this mathematical quantity which
we call neural task complexity that both
determines both the dimensionality and
recoverability of neural states-based
dynamics then we'll move on to single
trial data analysis you know how well
can we decode information from the brain
on a moment by
basis at each instant of time and will
find these phase transitions than our
ability to decode information and
accurately fit neural networks as a
function of the number of recorded
neurons and and recorded time and then
at the end I'll discuss an algorithm
which we call tensor components analysis
it's it's a method to perform multi
timescale neural dimension reduction so
neural dynamics exists on multiple time
scales right um the dynamics of hundreds
of milliseconds mediating cognition
behavior action perceptions and much
much longer time scale hours to days
that kind of dynamics mediates learning
so this algorithm can kind of
simultaneously reduce dimensionality
across neurons individual trials and
time across trials to recover so called
cell assemblies with coherent rapid
dynamics reflecting cognition and slower
dynamics reflecting learning so that's
kind of the outline of the talk so let's
jump in how many of you have experience
with neuroscience before I'm guessing
not many of you right
ok so small small fraction ok so again
just interrupt me with questions like
you know whenever you want and it's
pretty pretty informal all right
so here's an example of a neuroscience
experiment that this is the type of
experiment from which we'll be analysing
data right so this is data from Krishna
noise lab here at Stanford so the tip
and he and he studies motor control so
the types of experiments that he does is
he watches monkeys move their arms and
he records from the motor cortex of the
monkey and he tries to relate in your
all activity to behavior so here's
here's an experiment where a monkey is
holding a central target then a reach
target appears ok and then the monkey is
supposed to plan a reach to that target
so you can look at motor planning in
these types of experiments but then the
central target disappears ok that's the
signal that the monk you should start
reaching and then the monkey performs a
reach ok what happens is neural activity
during the planning period stays largely
stationary over time it doesn't change
much over time but the pattern of
activity is indicative of where the
monkey is going to move right but all
the action is happening here within this
about 600 millisecond window it takes
about 600 milliseconds from this monkey
to do this rapid reach
and there's a lot of dynamical neural
activity patterns during that 600
milliseconds across all the neurons okay
so they're recording from hundreds of
neurons using an electrode array
inserted into motor cortex and a more a
slightly more upstream region dorsal
premotor cortex okay they can they can
record about a hundred and nine well
isolated single units or a single
neurons you know by measuring the
extracellular voltage coming from these
neurons and that signifies when these
neurons spike write or emit action
potentials so here's some examples of
individual neuron firing rates you can
take the spikes and smooth them with a
small Gaussian window and get smooth
firing rates and then you can average
these over trials and this is what you
get for say one neuron right this is the
neurons activity pattern over time over
the six hundred millisecond window
across different reaches in different
directions and a different reach and
different reach speeds and extents okay
that's just one neuron here's another
neuron it looks sort of completely
different here's a third neuron it looks
it looks extremely different as well and
there's about a hundred more neurons
like this so these datasets are somewhat
complicated right there's a lot of
complexity in this neural dynamics
seemingly and so the question is how are
such datasets analyzed so just a very
simple approach that a lot of
neuroscientists take is you measure the
simultaneous dynamics of about n neurons
during a task and then you find just say
for example using principal components
analysis that the dynamics lives in
quite a low dimensional space in the in
the ambience a hundred dimensional space
of recorded neurons so remember in
principal components analysis you take
every neural activity pattern across
neurons that occurs in any instant of
time and you decompose it into a set of
basis activity patterns and you
decompose it using a time dependent set
of waiting coefficients that's just PCA
and so you can visualize the dynamics in
this low dimensional state space by the
amplitude of each pattern present and
then you get this neural trajectory and
what a lot of works have found is that
you can explain a lot of the variants in
neural data using a relatively small
dimensions in this case about 10
dimensions despite the fact that you
recorded 100 neurons so there's lots of
work in neuroscience that recovers this
kind of state space dynamics and
interesting the state space dynamics
yields a remarkably insightful kind of
dynamical portrait of what computation
the circuit is doing so for example
these are the state space dynamics of a
locust antenna lobe when it's exposed to
two different odors and as you can see
the locust antenna lobe the transient
dynamics of the system contains a lot of
information about the odor long before
the dynamics reaches as a respective
fixed point which is odor dependent so
it's processing information on the
transients this is data for a monkey
prefrontal cortex where the monkeys
trained to detect different frequencies
on its arm and you see that most of the
variants in the neural data accounts for
the passage of time in the task rather
than the different frequencies which is
sort of interesting finding this is this
is data for a monkey prefrontal cortex
during a context dependent
decision-making task and it turned out
that in this work done actually by
Christian Roy and Bill Newsome doesn't
done by their labs the shape of these
neural trajectories revealed an
algorithm for how the monkey is making
decisions and also you can record from
about all 80,000 neurons in the
zebrafish using calcium imaging and you
can fit that entire dataset in about
three dimensions and you're okay you
don't lose much variance so anyways this
is kind of a modus operandi for
competition on euro science with these
large data sets you recover the state
space dynamics and it's usually often
quite insightful and quite simple okay
but this raises some fundamental
conceptual questions again can we trust
these dynamical portraits of circuit
competition despite recording so few
neurons how would the shape of these
portraits change if we recorded more
neurons did we do we even get their
shape right we make scientific
inferences based on their shape did we
get the shape right why is there
dimensionality so low what is the origin
of the simplicity would it increase if
we recorded more neurons and more
generally what if anything at all can we
learn about a large about large
dynamical networks it's such an
overwhelming level of under sampling and
so basically can we obtain a predictive
theory of experimental design that can
you know tell us
many neurons we should record as a
function of the complexity of the task
or something like that so I don't have
the picture so I should say this was
work done by a grad student in my lab
app a Ron Gow ok so let me just give you
the take-home message of the first third
of the talk which is basically we define
this new mathematical quantity called
neural task complexity it takes into
account two distinct sources of
information the sort of complexity of
the task the monkey or the animal is
asked to do and the smoothness of neural
dynamics and we prove a theorem saying
that the dimensionality of neural data
is upper bounded by this neural task
complexity then we show that motor
cortical data is actually as high
dimensional as possible given this
neural task complexity which implies
that in future experiments if we record
more neurons without an increase in the
complexity of the task we won't
necessarily get richer datasets as
measured at least by their
dimensionality and moreover we can
recover conditions for accurate recovery
of dynamic portraits we can show that
the act of neural measurement is like
doing a random projection as curious how
many of you are familiar with random
projections this is the SI s Department
so again a surprisingly small fraction
ok ok what we'll go over random
projection theory but it's a very
beautiful theory we can show that what
neurophysiologists have been doing for
the last 50 years is essentially doing a
random projection which is kind of an
interesting connection and then based on
this we can show that past results ie
existing dynamic portraits are likely to
be accurate despite recording so few
neurons ok ok so what is this no I don't
have the ok it's ok well so what is this
neural task complexity so we can think
about the manifold of neural States that
are that are explored by the experiment
as an embedding of the behavioral
manifold into neural activity space
right and the basic idea is here's a
monkey reaching to eight directions ok
and you have some reach extend to reach
time ok and you trial average all of
this so the manifold of behavioral
States explored by the monkey is roughly
a cylinder
ramit rise by the angle of the reach and
the egg time into the reach okay or
duration of the reach okay now this
trial average this manifold in under the
trial average neural dynamics gets
embedded into some kind of complicated
cylinder that we don't really understand
fully okay but we can characterize the
complexity of this of this cylinder by
two things roughly the volume of the of
the behavioral manifold which is the
numerator of this of this quantity so so
let's say you have a general manifold
that has K intrinsic coordinates right
here it's to intrinsic coordinates in
this example a one egg one is theta
sorry one is 2pi or the solid angle and
one is the duration the length of the
reach so this has a certain volume but
that gets embedded into this into the
space and there's some volume of a unit
cell of how much you move before things
curve it's sort of like an
autocorrelation length so let's say that
I moved in this direction or let's say
that this this section or cell of the
manifold roughly got matched to this
section or cell of the manifold where
there wasn't much change in the in the
curvature then this entire section the
manifold roughly explores only one
dimension in firing rate space but then
let's say you have to move a certain
distance along each dimension of this
manifold to get to another another cell
that explores a different dimension
right so then roughly the total number
of dimensions that could possibly be
explored is the volume of the behavioral
manifold divided by the volume of the
unit cell over which the manual the
manifold doesn't really curve that much
okay
so just intuitively this is what's the
measure of neural task complexity our
theory gives us a way to extract these
autocorrelation lengths and of course
the experimentalist determines the
volume of the behavioral manifold that's
explored and so this ratio is the neural
task complexity and there's a constant
involved that's also given by the theory
right
so roughly you can prove a theorem that
says that the neural dimensionality is
upper bounded by the minimum of this
neural task complexity measure and the
number of recorded neurons so at least
on a high level this should be overall
intuitive a manifold that has larger
volume ie bigger numerator and is more
Wiggly ie smaller denominator can
potentially explore more dimensions okay
all right so now let's go back to the
neural data in primate motor cortex
again there are about a hundred million
neurons controlling 650 skeletal muscles
and in these experiments recorded about
a hundred neurons the pca dimensionality
which is roughly the number of principal
components you need to explain 70
percent of the variance across all eight
reaches is about seven the
dimensionality to explain just one reach
the the the variance in your activity
across one reach is about three point
three there's a particular measure of
dimensionality that we're using called
it's something called the participation
ratio of the eigen value spectrum of the
neuron by neuron covariance matrix which
roughly measures how many principal
components are active okay and a certain
participation ratio for a wide variety
of spectra corresponds to how many PCs
you need to keep 70% of variance
explained it turns out that 70% is not
an important number we could multiply
the participation ratio by a constant
fraction and we could get up to 90% it
would be the same exact theory okay so
so then again the the puzzle is these
numbers are much smaller than the total
number of neurons and again why is that
what's limiting the complexity have we
found something intrinsic about brain
dynamics that makes it simple or is the
simplicity of brain dynamics a
consequence of the simplicity that's
asked the monkeys asked to perform okay
so it turns out the latter is true if
you compute the task complexity of the
neural task complexity it's about 4.2
for a single region 10 for multiple
regions ok so as you can see the neural
dimensionality is close to this upper
bound ok so this suggests
so the implication is the neural
dimensionality is not necessarily small
but it's almost as large as possible
given the simplicity of the task and
this makes certain predictions if you
vary the complexity of the task by
varying the duration of the reach or
equivalently the amount of time of the
reach that you analyze then if indeed
the dimensionality of the data is
limited by the complexity of the task
then the dimensionality should vary
linearly with that time that you keep
okay that's prediction number one
prediction number two the number of
neurons in the data set is kind of
irrelevant in this case if you vary the
number of neurons in the data set the
dimensionality should roughly be
unchanged right because it's the
complexity of the task that's
eliminating the dimensionality so it
doesn't really matter that you measured
100 neurons if you reduce the neuron
count you shouldn't change the
dimensionality so prediction number 1 is
verified right as you vary the task
complexity by varying the duration of
the research you analyze you find that
the dimensionality increases with the
reach duration it hugs this kind of
dimensionality upper bounds set by the
complexity of the task and - as you drop
even 60% of the neurons the
dimensionality remains largely unchanged
ok so ok oops ok so that's the the most
boring part of the talk the next most
interesting part is what about the shape
of these trajectories dimensionality is
one thing but did we get the entire
shape of these trajectories correct ok
so what just to introduce the ideas what
is an intuitive situation where you
could record a subset of neurons in a
circuit but still get its state space
dynamics correct so here's an example
here's the simplest visualizable example
where you have 3 neurons so this is a
firing rate of neuron one firing rate of
neuron to firing rate of neuron 3
for whatever reason let's say neural
activity patterns that are explored
during during this this experiment live
on a one-dimensional manifold and it's
curved but not too curved ok and it's
roughly randomly oriented with respect
to the single neuron axes ok
so then it's kind of clear that even if
you don't measure all three neurons you
only let's say you only get to measure
two of the neuron
you see a shadow of the full state space
dynamics of the brain on to the
coordinate subspace spanned by the two
neurons that you do get to measure and
you can see that it doesn't matter which
two neurons you measure you get the same
answer and that answer is roughly
similar to what you get if you recorded
all the neurons okay of course life
doesn't need to be that rosy it could
have been the case that for example
neuron 2 were doing all the work so that
this manifold is access aligned to the
single neuron axes and then of course if
you only get to record a subset of
neurons that subset better including
your on to right so this is kind of a
pessimistic picture okay this picture
will arise if and ural activity patterns
are distributed across neurons okay okay
so let's actually hope for the best and
hope that the brain is in this regime
and not in some other regime not in this
regime okay then let's pursue the
theoretical consequences of the brain
being in that regime and derive some
theoretical consequences then test those
consequences in the actual brain to see
if this regime is a good enough
approximation okay so so this is a very
simple picture to analyze but how do we
make it quantitative and think about it
in much higher dimensions where the
number of recorded neurons is a hundred
to a thousand the dimensionality of this
manifold may be higher than one and so
on and so forth right so how do we
generalize that well let's say that this
neural manifold
is indeed randomly oriented with respect
to the single neuron axes that's a
statement that can be made precise but
we'll just keep it intuitive for now
then an experiment that we can do ie
measure a random subset of M neurons
becomes equivalent to an experiment we
cannot yet do which is measure and
random linear combinations of all
neurons so imagine you have a magical
electrode that measures a random
weighted sum of all the neurons another
magical electrode that measures another
random weighted sum of all the neurons
and you have M of these electrodes right
okay so why are these two experiments
completely equivalent to
each other if the neural manifold is
randomly oriented well this experiment
corresponds to projecting the neural
state space dynamics onto a coordinate
subspace
whereas this experiment corresponds to
projecting this neural dynamics onto a
randomly oriented subspace ie it's a
random projection so if the neural
manifold is randomly oriented with
respect to the coordinate subspaces to
begin with then projecting under a
coordinate subspace and projecting onto
a random subspace are equivalent to each
other right so if this assumption is
true then the act of neural measurement
is equivalent to the act of random
projection okay
so let's assume that's true for now okay
and let's derive consequences so now
let's review the theory of random
projections it's really a beautiful
theory that underlies compressed sensing
and and a lot of ideas in signal
recovery in an under sampled measurement
regime in computer science and EE and
signal processing so what happens often
is of course signals that were
interested in live in a high ambient
dimensional space say images the ambient
dimensionality is the number of pixels
for grayscale images but of course the
signals of interest don't explore this
full high dimensional space they live on
a much lower dimensional space for
example sparse signals live in a union
of coordinate sub sub spaces you could
have a finite number of points or you
could have a smooth manifold okay now
let's say that you randomly project this
space down to a lower dimensional space
using a random projection matrix so
you're projecting n-dimensional space
down to M dimensional space so a is an N
by M matrix s as a signal of interest in
our context is the set of neural like
neural firing rates of all the neurons
in the brain region and X is a set of
neural firing rates of of M recorded
neurons okay again the neural activity
patterns that we observe live in some
locational sub manifold in n dimensional
space and a critical question is when
will the geometry of this manifold be
preserved under a random projection by
the preservation of geometry we mean the
following let's consider two points in
the high dimension
space and consider the distance between
them measured under a Euclidean metric
in the high dimensional space so that's
sa minus SB for example then you project
it down to the low dimensional space and
up to a normalization you measure the
distance between the two points in the
low dimensional space so this is the
fractional error in distances measured
in the high dimensional space relative
to the low dimensional space okay now
this is for two points of course you
don't want to just preserve the
distances between two points you want to
preserve distances between all possible
pairs of points but not in the full
space only on the manifold that you care
about okay so we can define the
distortion as the max over all pairs of
points of this da be measure let's call
that epsilon so epsilon is the worst
case distortion over all pairs of points
okay epsilon is a random variable
because your projection is a random
matrix okay or a random subspace okay so
there are theorems about the behavior of
epsilon and its scaling with the number
of dimensions and with n K and M
basically okay this is the most
important theorem that will will invoke
this is work by Richard Barone you can
Michael waken actually these are old
slides we have some work on some work
that sharpens these results and gets
better bounds it's on our website called
random projections of random manifolds
but basically the theorem is the
following as long and I'm gonna use
neuroscience language here okay as long
as the number of recorded neurons M or
the dimensionality of the subspace is
bigger than up to an order of magnitude
one over epsilon squared times K the
intrinsic dimensionality this manifold
times the logarithm of the curvature
times the volume of the manifold okay
then the worst case distortion is indeed
order epsilon with very very high
probability over the random choice of
projection okay so this is interesting
the ambient dimensionality in our
context the total number of neurons in
the brain region doesn't matter at all
what matters is the intrinsic
dimensionality of your model manifold
and it's curvature and volume
okay and of course the distortion level
that you'd like to get right
okay now this actually makes a striking
prediction okay that we can now test a
neural data part of the business of a
theoretical neuroscientist is taking
theory and coming up with a way to test
it in neural data so this is the
prediction okay if you convert this
random projection theory into
neuroscience language it's saying the
number of neurons you need to get a
certain distortion is proportional to
the logarithm of talent of this neural
task complexity remember neural task
complexity was the volume of the
manifold in the numerator times the
curvature or one over the volume of an
autocorrelation cell so actually this
log of C times volume mathematically
becomes the logarithm of the same neural
task complexity measure that upper
bounded dimensionality okay so what this
is saying is it's saying that if you
were to reduce the number of neurons or
change the complexity of the task it's
saying that the ISO contours of constant
distortion form a straight line in a
plane spanned by the number of neurons
you record and the logarithm of the
complexity of the task in our case where
our task is just reaches along a single
dimension or reaches along a single axis
the complexity of task is the duration
of the reach okay so it's the logarithm
of time now of course we'd like to
record all of the neurons in in the
motor cortex under the most complicated
behavior possible but we don't have that
we have a data set with a finitely
complex task and we have about 109
neurons so what we can do is we can
again vary the complexity of the task by
varying the amount of data that we
analyze and we can sub sample neurons
and we can recover the state space
dynamics of the circuit using a smaller
number of neurons for any given task
complexity and compare its distortion
relative to that which you would get if
you recorded all if you took all the
neurons that you recorded okay so you
will get some distortion it'll vary as a
function but what this is saying is on
this weird plane that's linear in the
number of neurons that you keep but
logarithmic in time
if you vary along this axis along a
straight line you'll get the same
distortion and let's say you allow
yourself to be more generous for a given
task complexity you allow more neurons
you'll get a lower Distortion but again
there'll be a different ISO contour of
distortion that's again a straight line
okay so this makes now a testable
prediction we can actually do this in
neural data from the monkey's brain and
actually plot these ISO contours of
constant distortion and what you find is
that the prediction is strikingly
verified so this is again the the number
of recorded neurons that we keep this is
the neural task complexity this is a
logarithmic axis this is a linear axis
this is the distortion level and the ISO
contours are indeed straight lines now
remember this isn't just an empty
mathematical test of a theory for which
we already have a theorem ie ran two
projection Theory this is a test of the
very assumption that random projection
Theory constitutes a good model for the
process of neural measurement okay and
it turns out it does seem to constitute
a good model for that process at least
as measured by this prediction or as
assessed by this prediction okay all
right
so that's the first third of the talk
again let me just summarize so basically
whenever you look at the dimensionality
of neural dynamics in the brain to ask
if it's complicated or not what you
really want to do is compare the
dimensionality to the neural task
complexity if it's as high as that then
your dimensionality is constrained by
the complexity of the task and the
smoothness and real data only if it's
much less than that have you discovered
additional intrinsic dynamic constraints
in the data beyond task complexity and
smoothness and also this this random
projection Theory actually yields a
surprisingly optimistic message for
Neuroscience is that in many many cases
because the task isn't that complicated
the neural manifold doesn't have that
high volume is not that curved we can
get away with recording a very small
number of neurons okay so that's really
good news actually for Neuroscience and
as we start doing more and more
complicated tasks it turns out that the
number of neurons we simultaneously
record is not really the bottleneck
it's exploring the manifold that becomes
the bottleneck and this actually impacts
the design of technology in neuroscience
you would much rather have technologies
that allow you to record neurons for
long periods of time as you go to a more
complex task because the time it takes
to explore a manifold grows
exponentially with the dimensionality
intrinsic dimensionality is manifold but
the number of neurons you need to record
grows linearly
okay so considerations like this can
drive can drive the design of technology
as well in your sons ok so let's move on
to the second part of the talk would ya
sure that full international space oh
yeah so we do it in the hundred and nine
dimensional space compared to like M
dimensional space where m is less than
100 to mention allottee really doesn't
matter right so even if you have like 10
to the 6 neurons you'd get a similar
answer because the the volume of the
manifold is so small and its intrinsic
dimensionality is 2 right so if you have
like no no that's a consequence of the
theory so okay so okay so what'swhat's
theory and what's Assumption right so if
the random projection theory is a good
model for the act of electrophysiology
measurement given that assumption we
expect the exact same answer if we did
the analysis I did with a hundred nine
year olds versus ten to the six neurons
given the intrinsic dimensionality of
the manifold is only two right two is
much much bigger than hundred nine
yeah to dementia no no that's not an
assumption okay so yeah yeah yeah only
for this experiment right so for other
experiments there will be a different
dimensionality but then you plug in that
dimensionality into the theory and you
get an answer for how many neurons if
you take a subset of your 109 recorded
channels or multiple random randomly
chosen subsets yeah how much variability
is there if you perform this analysis on
the subsets you go between subsets yeah
so that the distortion between subsets
it's similar to the distortion between
any subset and the the full set right
because of triangle inequalities in
geometry it's a similar answer actually
I didn't even include this because this
is even more recent work that this hat
actually has a really cool practical
implication so when people record like
hundreds of neurons they stick an
electrode array into the brain now each
electrode could be listening for it to
multiple neurons so there's a
complicated clustering problem each
neuron leaves a slightly different
waveform on the electrode and so in
order to get individual neurons you need
to solve a clustering problem it's
called spike sorting right spike sorting
is the bane of existence of experimental
neuroscientists right because you're
measuring random linear combinations of
neurons in your electrodes and you need
to deem ixth at random than your
combination it turns out we have a
separate paper under review and also in
the bio archive called accurate recovery
of state space dynamics without spike
sorting this theory says that if you
what I've told you one consequence of
series is that if you record a hundred
neurons out of 109 you get the right
stay space dynamics this also says if
you don't do spike sorting but you just
- you just look at the high frequency
activity on the on the electrodes and
just do dimensional reduction directly
in that without spike sorting you get
the same state space dynamics so what
this does is it on
like a whole bunch of data sitting on
hard drives that people have not spikes
sorted and it makes that available for
for analysis at least at the level
states based dynamics so that's another
paper that's on our website and is under
review as on bar archives so that was
done by Eric Troutman is the lead author
in Christian choice lab into
collaboration team I live in his so and
by the way this is also part of the
reason why brain machine interfaces work
why you can decode at these simple
movements from the brain by only
recording 100 neurons of course if you
try to decode more complicated movements
you probably have to record more neurons
but this is going in a single trial data
analysis which will because you need to
in a BMI you don't want to recover the
trial average trajectory of the of the
arm that doesn't really mean anything
for patient you want to decode the
instantaneous intentions of the patient
and translate them into the action the
prosthetic device so that's why single
trial data analysis is of course
extremely important so let's move on to
that unless there's any other questions
on the first third okay so okay so what
do I mean by by a single trial theory
right so here here's kind of the setup
okay we always have limited experimental
resources the resources are M is the
number of neurons we can simultaneous
record P or T is the number of training
stimuli or amount of time we can observe
the brain okay let's say you're
observing is let's say in a brain
machine to design a brain machine
interface you're watching a monkey for
example reaching multiple times on each
reach you record the individual
trajectory of the reach and the
individual neural tree the neural
trajectory in the brain right and you do
this many times and you build up a
dictionary so you get a certain amount
of training data then subsequently on
held-out data say a single trajectory
from the monkey's brain neuro structure
from the monkey's brain you'd like to
construct a brain machine interface that
decodes the trajectory the monkeys wants
to move its arm on a single trial right
so P or T is the amount of training data
you have for subsequent single trial
analyses and of course there's always
some signal-to-noise ratio or try to
trial reproducibility in our data even
if you show the same visual state
to a brain neural activity patterns will
vary from trial to trial it's a major
open question whether this variation is
irrelevant noise or it's just the rest
of the brain thinking and therefore it's
very interesting cognitive variables
that are changing from from trial to
trial okay then you also have some
measure of the complexity of the
experiment of the neural data so some
measure of the complexity of the stimuli
or behavior or latent variable latent
cognitive variables or thoughts or
manifold the visited neural States so
this is some complexity measure so then
the question is given these limited
experimental resources and the
complexity of the thing we're trying to
decode or the neural data how do how
well can we decode behavior on single
trials and how well can we learn the
structure of unobserved layton cognitive
variables contributing to this trial to
trial variability in the brain good we
ideally like to have a theory to help us
design experiments before they're done
okay so let's consider for example a
very simple relatively simple warm-up
problem which is inferring latent
subspaces in which data live so here's
here's the idea let's say that on
individual trials there's some latent
space like a low dimensional space of
things that the monkey can think
movements that the monkey can imagine or
even stimuli that the monkey sees in
which case they're not latent variables
that actually observed variables
okay so there's some low dimensional
space and on individual trials given by
these white dots these latent variables
take different values in this low
dimensional space okay now in the
monkey's brain this is the full N
dimensional space of all the relevant
neurons in the circuit for each of these
latent space States there's a different
neural activity pattern and we can
imagine just a simple linear embedding
for example again if it's a non linear
curved embedding and the curvature is
not that high then the these low
dimensional not - curved manifolds live
within a subspace of dimensionality not
higher not much higher than the
intrinsic dimensionality of the curved
manifold okay but then again there's
noise there's trial trial variability in
the data so you're not always living
directly on the manifold you're living
off the manifold okay
now so that's the state of the brain
that's the assumed state of the brain in
this very simple model okay now what do
we get to observe again we don't get to
observe all the activity in the brain we
get to observe a subset of neural
activity patterns okay and we only get
to observe the noisy activity patterns
we do not get to see the latent subspace
and we do not get to see the clean
single trial latent variables on trial
to trial right so given only these X's
can we infer both the orientation of
this latent subspace and on individual
trials can we denoise the data and
extract from from the record M recorded
neurons the latent variable that was
driving your elective 'ti okay whether
its internal cognitive States or motor
actions or stimulus evoke response ins
okay so the again the quantitative
parameters you have n neurons and total
neurons on the circuit you only get to
record M of them and you only get P
stimuli or P latent States okay and
let's say the stimuli are encoded by
this K dimensional linear subspace okay
then what regimes of M and P and K and
the SNR can we correctly recover both
the subspace in its dimensionality okay
so we can formalize this algebraically
as a low rank matrix denoising problem
as follows
so let's imagine that the case stimuli
or k latent variables that you see can
be arranged so IP the p latent variables
that you see each of them is a core is a
point in a K dimensional space so they
can be arranged as the columns of a K by
P matrix so each column is one latent
variable and these are the different
different trials that you see okay P
trials
okay these latent states are embedded
into the brain
through some embedding matrix or in some
subspace and I'll describe that subspace
by the columns of an orthonormal matrix
okay this is an N by K matrix now again
you don't get to observe all n neurons
you only get to observe a subset of them
and this is the random sampling operator
which is each row is just one neuron is
active has a1 and the rest are zero
right so these each row tells you which
neuron you're observing and there's M
neurons okay plus you have observation
noise which I'm just going to assume is
iid across neurons and trials
it's kind of an idealization of the
problem all right and so this is your
data your data is the matrix s times u
times X plus Z and what you'd like to do
is from this data recover you or at
least the projection of U onto the
recorded subspace and for each
individual trial record the recover the
columns of X so X is hiding inside your
data and you'd like to recover it okay
what do I mean by the SNR by the SNR I
mean the the signal-to-noise ratio of
individual neurons so if I were to trial
average right on four different latent
variables I'd get a different firing
rate and if I take the squared that the
power in the trial average firing rate
that's the variance of the signal but
then if I condition on the latent
variable and look at the variability
condition on that that's the single
trial noise and that has a variance
Sigma squared N and so the SNR is as
usual in in EE the variance of the
signals of the variance of the noise
okay so I have a well-defined problem in
the interests of how many of you really
like math and theory here okay
interesting
there are many willing to admit that
they don't all right so uh-huh yeah good
for them yeah so I love math and theory
but I'm gonna break my heart and
hopefully not piss off a lot of people
and I'm gonna skip the theory but it
involves really interesting random
matrix theory and low rank matrix
denoising and high dimensional
statistics and so on and so forth
but I'm going to tell you the answer the
answer is the following as long as the
product of the signal-to-noise ratio and
the square root of the number of
recorded neurons and the number of
training stimuli that you have
is bigger than the dimensionality of the
latent subspace right and of course two
extra constraints the number of neurons
must exceed the dimensionality of the
latent subspace and the number of trials
Layton subspace but as long as these
three conditions hold then you can do
what I said we would like to do we can
accurately recover these unseen
variables we can accurately recover the
orientation of the subspace and then
subsequently on single trials if I give
you a new X here that I've you've never
seen before you because you know the
subspace you can project it down under
the subspace and recover the latent
variables okay so this again makes a
striking prediction about neural data
okay it says that there's a interesting
hyperbolic trade-off between two very
different experimental resources the
number of neurons that you record and
the number of trials that you take
because your ability to do single trial
data analysis only depends on the
product so you can always trade them off
against each other okay so okay so what
this says is well we can we can do this
in neural data again neural data
collected from Krishna annoys lab so it
again says so now K has been replaced
with D in this slide but but but it's
the same concept it says there's a
hyperbolic phase transition boundary in
the M by plea plane and by P plane
number of recorded neurons a number of
trials okay so this we confirm this in
simulations so here we simulate random
smooth neural trajectories with an SNR a
very small SNR of 0.02
living in a four dimensional space and
we ask how many you know we we sub
sample a number of neurons we sub sample
a number of trials and we ask how well
can we will cover the dimensionality of
the sub space and the orientation the
sub space so you can define an overlap
between sub spaces where it's 1 if
they're identical and 0 if they're share
no common dimensions they're completely
orthogonal it generalizes as a cosine of
the angle between two one-dimensional
some spaces okay and so as you can see
there is this hyperbolic phase
transition boundary and simulated data
but that's just a confirmation of our
theory okay the question is is this
theory at all relevant to the brain
because the brain isn't making the IAG
assumptions that we're making it isn't
isn't isn't making a linear subspace
assumption that we're making but we
expect that qualitatively the structure
should show up partially because of what
we know about universality in random
matrix theory we used a random matrix
theory to derive if these this
hyperbolic phase transition boundary and
a lot of results in random matrix Theory
doesn't depend in detail on the
distribution of individual elements in
that random matrix so emergent
properties like the eigen value spectrum
and so on and so forth don't depend on
detail distributional assumptions about
individual matrix elements they do
depend on having weak correlations
between the matrix elements but any case
we can test this in a monkey so what we
did was we again looked at data from the
Shenoy lab the same data that i talked
about before in a trial average setting
but we look at them in a single trial
setting right and we use something
called Gaussian process factor analysis
it's basically a souped up version of
pca with some smoothing along the
temporal direction to extract latent
trajectories neural trajectories in 147
trials for reaches to a single target
okay and we use a different algorithm
even from from just low rank matrix
denoising
we use we infer the dimensionality
explored by these Leighton trajectories
using cross validated Gaussian process
factor analysis so there's a parameter
which is how many dimensions that you
keep and you can choose that parameter
using cross-validation how well you
predict single trials on held out data
and so on the noise in the data is pink
and temporally correlated it's not iid
in time and trials so there's a
different noise in the data okay but
still sorry for the the resolution you
still see this hyperbolic trade-off
between how well you infer the subspace
the dimensionality of the subspace and
how well you get the right subspace now
again
this is a situation where you only had a
hundred nine neurons so we infer the
dimensionality of the subspace and the
using all of the neurons and we define
the correct subspace to be whatever
subspace we got using all of the neurons
then we send all of the trials then we
sub sample neurons and we sub sample
trials when we measure the
dimensionality again and we measure the
subspace overlap between the subspace
that we got using fewer neurons and
fewer trials with the projection of the
quote/unquote true subspace using all
neurons on all trials onto the subspace
of the subset of neurons that we keep
okay but but to make a long story short
you again see an interesting hyperbolic
trade-off between neurons and trials so
this is kind of random matrix theory
operating in the brain right there is
this trade-off between two very
different resources on neurons and
trials so in future experiments it's
really important to be cognizant of this
trade-off especially in the design of
experiments before the data is actually
collected okay there's another super
interesting question that we can ask in
terms of this what are we doing when
we're doing neuroscience so you're
you're familiar with sort of deep
learning and recurrent neural networks
and things like that so what people are
doing is they're again taking neural X a
neural data and they're recording a
subset of neurons looking at the
dynamics and fitting a recurrent neural
network to that dynamics okay now what
the heck is it that we're doing right
how is it that a recurrent neural
network fit to a hundred neurons it all
reflects anything about the dynamics of
the circuit you know using all the
neurons is there anything about the
circuit dynamics that we can get right
ie what the hell are we learning about
the brain by fitting neural networks to
the brain use it to a small subset of
neurons okay that's a super interesting
question right
especially because everybody's doing it
now and and and it's not clear what it
means when you do it
right so we also ask this question okay
so consider and we formalized it using
theory and we applied the theory to
linear neural networks but then we did
simulations and nonlinear neural
networks to show that the qualitative
structure of the theory holds also
nonlinear neural ironwork so what's the
setup of the problem we can formalize
this promise follows so consider some
high dimensional neural circuit with n
neurons again you only record to need to
record M of them the notation is all the
same for a finite amount of time T what
can we infer about the circuit dynamics
when M is much smaller than n and T is
not too large and of course in general
the answer is absolutely nothing okay
it's a seriously pessimistic problem in
this regime for arbitrary recurrent
neural networks however we might assume
some underlying simplicity about the
recurrent Network dynamics for example
for some reason than the the network
dynamics may be forced to live in a
kennel subspace okay because of the
recurrent connectivity now that we
imagine the recurrent connectivity is
constraining the activity patterns to
live in a low dimensional subspace okay
so then the question is for what region
regimes of M and T and K can we
correctly recover the dynamical
properties of the circuit so again we're
so so we'll work out the theory in a
linear model so this is a linear neural
network with a decay time constant of
tau it's kind of a discrete-time version
there's a recurrent connectivity and
this is a rank K matrix so basically
without this matrix activity would decay
to the origin but because of the rank K
nature of this matrix it's amplifying
activity patterns but only in K
dimensions okay and there's through some
noisy input that's we're just going to
take to be white noise here okay now
again you don't get to observe the full
stage you only observe a subset and this
is your random sampling matrix okay so
now what do people do they fit an
autoregressive model to Y of T okay but
what the heck does the autoregressive
model have fit to Y of T have to do with
an autoregressive model fit to X of T
when M is much much less than n when Y
is a much lower dimensional vector than
ax
so um there's interesting methods for
fitting these using subspace
identification and that leads to Hankel
matrices you do low-rank decomposition
so these Henkel matrices and and there's
some nice random matrix Theory you can
apply to these but let me just tell you
the the answer okay it turns out that
there's an again a phase transition in
the number of recorded neurons in the
amount of time that you record in that
in that plane okay
that whenever this so called Henkel
matrix has a gap in its eigen value
spectrum then so this is an example
where you have a thousand neurons a rank
for connectivity matrix and and and this
is kind of the time the the timescale of
single neurons right so now you get to
measure for a time duration of mm so so
roughly the number of observations is
2,000 divided by nine that's the
dimensionless ratio of the recording
time to the into time constant of the
circuit and then the number of neurons
is 200 not a thousands you're recording
one-fifth of the circuit and then you
ask you know I fit an autoregressive
model to Y so I get an autoregressive
matrix C right
oh sorry yes sorry I fit a latent
variable model to Y and I get this
latent dynamics a that I get from a
subset of neurons you could just ask did
I get the eigenvalues of the full matrix
correct right just the just the 200 by
200 matrix that I get on my observed
data have the same eigen values as the
thousand by thousand matrix okay and the
answer is for this regime yes right so
the red are the true eigenvalues and the
x of the estimated eigenvalues you
actually got the right answer so despite
some something you recovered some aspect
of the dynamics of the full circuit ie
no linear system the eigenvalues of the
connectivity matrix okay they're complex
because they're not a symmetric matrix
on the other hand if the Henkel matrix
doesn't have a gap there are errors in
the estimate of the eigenvalues okay so
for example with 50 neurons you cannot
do it where there's what 200 neurons you
can for the same amount of recording
time
okay again there's some so again here's
the phase transition number of recorded
neurons and in duration of time and
there's a hyperbolic phase transition
boundary that we get from theory there's
this is simulated data the transition in
the simulated data matches our theory on
this side where you have the product of
number of neurons and time exceeds the
threshold you get the correct
I can values and here you get incorrect
eigen values okay that's kind of the
take-home message so it's a very similar
story a trade-off between two very
different parameters number of neurons
in the amount of time you get to watch
the circuit okay okay we tried this a
nonlinear neural networks and we observe
similar hyperbolic trade-offs that shift
depending on the non-linearity okay so
then the last part of the talk I which I
think I can finish in about 10 minutes
yeah yeah okay this stuff actually is
out that the tensor components analysis
this is impress it at neuron and it's on
the buyer archive and on our website so
this last part is actually a practical
like algorithm to solve the following
problem okay and this is work done by
Alex Williams in my lab who kind of
spearheaded this work so the goal is how
do we simultaneously reduce the
dimensionality of data across again two
very different dimensions time within
trials right so remember neural data is
often organized into trials like the
monkey does something and maybe
initially it doesn't do it well then it
keeps doing it again and over time it
gets better and better at it okay and
then so so now you have two very
different time scale dynamics within a
single trial which could be a second the
monkey has is
doing something like reaching or
something like that the brain is having
this churning activity that that that's
correlated with the reaching but then
across many trials this dynamics is
slowly changing to reflect learning or
performance or improvement right so how
do we simultaneously obtain just low
dimensional descriptions of both time
with neural dynamics within trials
reflecting perception action
decision-making motor actions cooking
cognition and so forth and time across
trials reflecting learning and also
there's other really interesting state
changes your brain like how much
attention you're paying can Wayne from
wait wax and wane from time to time your
arousal state your changes in cognitive
state like monkeys could be thinking
different things on different trials
that are not under experimental control
and we like to extract all of that in an
unsupervised manner and especially
changes in cognitive state that are not
under experimental control must be
extracted in an unsupervised manner
because you don't have a covariate with
which to regress against neural data to
discover dimensions in your elec tivity
space that encode that covariant okay so
the idea we had was we treated these two
disparate time scales as two distinct
dimensions of a third order tensor with
the third axis being neurons okay so
here's the basic idea so we kind of
discussed trial average pca at the
beginning of the talk so here you have
neurons by time within trials and you
have the spikes of neurons then you have
another trial in another trial and let's
say you assume that all trials are
identical then you just average all the
trials and maybe smooth over time so you
get a matrix of neurons by time which
reflects the trial average firing rates
of all the neurons and you decompose it
using PCA so you you basically do a
matrix factorization where you write
this matrix as an outer product of
patterns across neurons and patterns
across time right okay but that's
assuming that individual trials are
statistically homogeneous right it's
assuming stationarity fundamentally when
an animal is learning you cannot assume
stationarity in fact learning is
tautologically non-stationary right so
so trial averaging will make processes
like learning and changes in cognitive
state invisible right so one way to deal
with that is to take these matrices
and just concatenate them across time
and then do pca right so then you
decompose it into a pattern across
neurons and then very very long patterns
across both time within trial and time
across trials okay
people sometimes do this but it isn't
very successful because there's so many
parameters involved in this
decomposition because there's nothing
constraining it's assuming that there's
nothing common across trials right each
individual trial could be completely
different it's not assuming anything
common whenever you're doing single
trial data analysis you're a tenth it
you're always making an assumption about
something that's common across trials
and something that varies across trials
okay and trial concatenated PC is not
making any assumptions about what's
common across trials there's too many
parameters so it's often not that useful
in single trial data okay the approach
that we used was to use something called
canonical poly attic tensor
decomposition for neuroscientists we
called it tensor components analysis to
rhyme with PCA so the TCA anyways but
but that the technique the mathematical
technique that we're using is something
called canonical poly attack tensor
decomposition it's a generalization of
PC in the following sense you can take
these neurons bye-bye time matrices and
stack them into a third order tensor and
then decompose this tensor into a sum of
Rank 1 outer products of Rank 1 tensor
or sum of Rank 1 tensors ok so each
component or each component gives you
three factors it gives you a pattern of
activity across neurons which you can
roughly think of a Salle assembly or a
or a pattern that varies coherently
somehow right it gives you a temporal
factor which is a kind of dynamical mode
shared by these neurons across time
within trials okay and then it gives you
a trial of trial factor which is just an
a scalar amplitude variable that scales
up or down this pattern across neurons
in this pattern across time okay so it's
like a gain modulation factor right and
this is this
is just it's just what it does it's a
completely unsupervised algorithm you
throw at the data center its data tensor
it spits this stuff out okay
it turns out that there's very simple
off-the-shelf algorithm is actually
surprisingly useful in neuroscience so
one way to think about this is this is
completely equivalent to a very simple
gain modulated neural network where
let's say these are the neurons that
you're observing or recording you assume
that there's some number of latent
factors here corresponding to the number
of outer products you have okay you
assume that each latent factor has a has
its own temporal waveform the shape of
this temporal waveform is common across
all trials so that's the assumption of
commonality across all trials so this is
the shape of one factor waveform this is
the shape of another and this in shape
of another but what's changing across
trials is the amplitude of each waveform
okay that varies across trials so
basically what you're doing is you're
summarizing each trial let's say there's
K factors you're summarizing it by K
numbers the amplitude of each waveform
okay and that's what's driving the
activity and it turns out that this is
if you do CP decomposition on just
observations of activity patterns and
noisy versions of them you can
accurately recover all of these factors
now what's really interesting is PCA is
fundamentally a subspace recovery
algorithm right PCA only gives you
unique principal components if you have
an orthogonality assumption on your on
your principal components without such
an orthogonal the assumption you just
recover a subspace if you keep K
principal components here the individual
factors actually matter right this
actually recovered the individual
factors identically and it doesn't
require them to be orthogonal PCA
applied to different unfoldings of the
tensor doesn't work independent
components analysis doesn't work but but
but the CP decomposition works okay
that's kind of to be expected because we
did it on data drawn from the model and
so that's it's to be expected
yeah
who the corners you can keep getting
practice and practice in practice
yes we are various method yeah so we
have three methods for choosing the
number of factors you weren't a reviewer
for a paper yes we demolished that
review so uh we already had two two
methods so I mean this is a problem with
any unsupervised data analysis algorithm
right whether it's clustering how do you
choose the number of clusters whether
it's principal components how many
components do you keep and so on
there's several methods you can use you
can look at the reconstruction error as
a function of the number of factors that
you keep and you might stop when you get
diminishing returns you could look at
the similarity of the factors that you
get because this is a non convex
optimization problem so if you start
from different racial conditions you may
get slightly different factors so you
could run it multiple times from
different initial conditions and align
the factors and see how similar the
factors are as you start including more
and more factors they'll stop being
similar to each other the other thing
you can do is you can do
cross-validation you can hold out stuff
in the tensor okay and do the
decomposition only on elements you keep
and ask how well you can predict the
other elements all three methods are
great ways of choosing it but actually
the other thing is as usual and
unsupervised dimensional error reduction
techniques this number of factors that
you keep allows you to trade-off between
two very important variables the
complexity of the model and the
interpretability of the model and we
just observed that the answers that we
got were pretty robust as we change the
number of factors usually what happens
is as you start increasing factors
individual factors split into two
factors and so on well all the other
factors remain the same yeah
monkeys learning over time monkeys get
faster so the never sampled excellent
goes away dramatically excellent so um
there's various ways to deal with that
you can time warp the data you could
keep roughly the fastest trials and
truncate the data and so on there's
various what you can align the data to
interesting events and keep fixed
amounts of data around the interesting
events like movement onset or something
like that your scientists have dealt
with this time immemorial because every
individual trial is a different duration
and those are the kind of the techniques
that people use and we use those same
techniques it's not a smooth expansion
to the monkey because we did this on the
monkey so let me tell you what we did
this so we did this in an artificial
recurrent neural network and it told us
how the network learns we're actually
using tensor components analysis tool to
analyze learning dynamics in deep deep
networks actually and it seems to yield
very interesting results there this is
that we also applied it to I have that
slide I don't have it on the item we
also applied it to data from Rochester's
lab also here at Stanford on mice
navigating a maze and it yielded
interesting effects in the mouse but let
me focus on the monkey here so this is
an interesting experiment
how much time do I have okay so let me
try to do this in three minutes and I
can stay afterwards for some questions
but of course nobody needs to stay but
but here's the basic idea this is a BMI
perturbation experiment so what they did
was they had a monkey reaching and they
developed a brain machine interface the
translated neural activity into the
intended direction of movement of the
monkeys arm then they tied the monkeys
arm down and they had a neural cursor
they had the monkeys brain directly
control the cursor so because the BMI
was trained on the monkeys natural
reaching patterns the monkey could
control the cursor so if
was asked to reach here the monkey could
think and make the cursor move here and
so on okay and this is the these are
individual trajectories to a particular
target and you can see the trajectories
are not bad there's some overshoot and
return and all that but it's sort of
working then they do this vicious
perturbation where they rotate the the
cursor position cursor angle thirty
degrees compared to what the monkey is
expecting okay so now like if the
monkeys thinking that the cur that he
wants to move the cursor this way the
cursor will actually move this way okay
it's a vicious perturbation monkey
doesn't get it initially right after the
perturbation the monkey is still
thinking the cursor should move this way
but lo and behold the cursor moves this
way because the experimentalist tricked
the monkey and then over some late time
the monkey makes a correction and then
moves moves back to here so these are
trot individual trials right after the
perturbation but then at much later
trials it starts to get better and it
adapts the monkey's brain adapts or
learns to deal with the rotated BMI
right and so the monkey starts to do
more straight reaches okay now we want
to discover what's going on in the brain
during this and of course individual
neurons are super complicated it's hard
to understand by looking at them so we
just through the neural data tenser
which is again order a hundred neurons
by six hundred milliseconds by about a
hundred you can see about a hundred
trials okay and we found that three
components by the various measures of
choosing the number of components were
sufficient to explain most of the
variance in the data okay and so we
recovered these three components so
these so this component 1 2 & 3 ok these
are the different cell assemblies
involved in each components but let's
look at the the dynamics okay so the
interesting one is the across trial so
you have some trials before the
perturbation then a bunch of trials
after the perturbation ok so there's
some component that's active before the
perturbation and so this is like the
baseline state of the brain ok and it's
active very very early
in the reach its active super early like
so it's implementing this kind of
movement okay
interestingly the baseline state of the
brain which was good before the
perturbation becomes maladaptive or bad
after the perturbation but it doesn't
get extinguished the brain keeps it
around what instead happens as two
components are born after the
perturbation and they have different
dynamics one gets active right after the
perturbation and within a trial it's
active very late and what's that's doing
is it implements this late stage
correction but then over time the late
stage correction dies down and this
early stage correction or mid stage
correction gets activated by the brain
and it's active in the middle period
right and it's presumably implementing
this and compensating for this thing
right and so that's how the brain is
kind of doing it it has a it hasn't yeah
it has these two components that mediate
the learning now remember that this was
just extracted completely from the
monkey's brain this data analysis
algorithm never had access to the
behavior nevertheless do individual
components predict anything about the
behavior so as you mentioned as the
monkey gets better and better it gets
faster at the task right
these reaches are pretty slow because it
has to do a long correction these
reaches are faster
so one behavioral one behavioral
correlative learning is the time it
takes to acquire the target so this is
just behavior okay this is on each trial
how long did it take to acquire the
target it's doing really well and fast
here after the prohibition goes up and
it comes down this looks a lot like this
component extracted from the neural data
okay they look strikingly similar it
turns out that they're actually quite
identical on a trial by trial their
basis so you can try to predict reach
time from this neural component directly
and we did that and now this is data
from across all eight directions okay
the black is behavior time to acquire
the target
the blue is extracted from mural data
alone okay and we're not doing a
regression because there's just a single
factor we were just scaling one
amplitude factor up to match best as
possible the time and you see there's a
lot of Co variation across trials so
this is what I mean by tensor components
analysis does D mixing I didn't show you
this but in many many data sets
individual factors tend to have a highly
interpretive --all meaning that can
often relate to a quantitative aspect of
behavior in this particular case there's
one neural component right which is a
corrective perturbation whose amplitude
dies off and it predicts the time it
takes to do the reach okay and that's it
so that's the end again pair on gouget a
lot of the work on the of the single
trial theory and Alex Williams did a lot
of the work on tensor component analysis
we actually have collaborations lots of
experimental labs and also working
theory of deep learning and stuff like
that but again Thanks so if you tried
anything other than monkeys yeah we
actually work with mice with flies we
haven't have some work in humans what
else salamanders yeah we're working a
bunch of things from the experimentalist
different animals are better for
different questions was there a
particular there presumably ethical
issues with working on people how do you
what so when people it's more like
psychology data that we work with so we
have some work on like a theories of how
infants develop concepts and there's all
these psychological studies of when
infants can learn categories and things
like that and neural networks learn
categories of the surgeons I now makes
it turns out neural networks and infants
learn categories with the same
we have a mathematical theory for why so
with humans mostly psychology data or
fMRI data but I just kind of stayed away
from that for my data just not because
it's not interesting but I've just
swamped with electrophysiology data from
actually human data under the right
circumstances yeah usually so there's
various modes for measuring data from
the human brain
there's fMRI there's EEG those are
non-invasive then there's a cog which
you can often do since a epilepsy
patients by putting surface electrodes
on the surface of the brain so you don't
get low-pass filtering through the skull
which you would get on surface EEG
that's done by for example Joseph's part
VC here we've looked at some of that
data but and then you can even put in
depth electrodes into the human brain
again only in patients that require that
kind of monitoring of the brain say to
excise some part of the brain for
epilepsy or something like that yes a
deep brain stimulation for Parkinson's
that's another method for treating
Parkinson's that's done but it's very
hard to get multi electrode data from
the human brain though that is being
done by Krishna shenoy and Jamie
Henderson here I don't have a picture of
how your probes look how do you get 100
probes something
oh there's various ways to do this
there's actually some new technology
called neuro pixel probes which is this
linear array and you slowly squish it
into the brain and wait for the brain to
stabilize and then you have electrodes
all along their array right there's also
surface electrodes which only allow you
to record from the surface of the brain
and it's it's a bed of electrodes a to
2d array of electrodes and you stick it
in a little bit into the brain
there's also calcium imaging where you
you can record fluorescence coming from
so calcium rushes in that gates an ion
channel that gates a particular molecule
to fluoresce and you measure the
fluorescence that's something that
happens
with these multi electrodes that you can
service some great that this stuff never
personally use some legends every but
how many hours how long a period of time
can you keep well that's a question yeah
it varies from technology technology for
some you can keep them in for months but
there's no guarantee that you'll get the
same neurons on day one versus day two
versus day three there's some churn and
people believe to different degrees
claims that you got the same you're on
over multiple days if you want to do
that kind of stuff you uh you do calcium
imaging and that's that you can get you
can stabili get neurons over many days
that's in the same your